my final report spends way too much time
in football you'll never make a living
at that hi I'm Gary Lineker and this is
what it takes the sport Bible
[Music]
let's have a look that's me as a a young
boy with goofy teeth and sticking out is
my childhood was actually stable loving
parents and supportive of my football
growing up really was just from my
memory just playing sport cricket in the
summer football or winter I was so
obsessed with sport cricket and
particularly football that my final
report from my head master said spends
way too much time in football it'll
never make a living at that
that's picture of me as always in all my
pictures of when I played football
pulling a face you know plan few local
teams it's so important I think the
difficulty of plan for your local team
is that perhaps him as too much because
it's difficult to leave I was 24 think
by the time I left Leicester but I had
to make that decision which was probably
the hardest I've had to make him my
whole career I've thought about it loads
of times about why I've you know why I
made it to the very top and other
players didn't and other players at more
time I mean even when I was a young
player playing Sunday footballer I
wasn't even best in my local team I
think it's just that I have kind of lots
of things going together obviously had
an inkling of how to score goals I had
incredible mental strengths I think
that's the most important thing I had
nothing kind of affected me I had great
Drive great ambition it was I think it
was it make sure things but I was always
incredibly quick and I had a football
brain I kind of worked out how to score
goals I worked out how to the tax base
how to gamble
and to make those opportunities camp so
there are all sorts of different things
that need to come together to culminate
in creating a player that can play at
the very top and
and I was lucky enough to have them and
lock-based parts well I think it's very
important to say that that you need a
lot of luck next vote so this was
obviously that the World Cup that
changed my life this kind of put onto
the world stage when in the Golden Boot
and it was a life-changing experience
didn't win the World Cup you know kind
of [ __ ] now that you know strengths
without bringing myself up too much is
that I could cope with the times when
the ball wouldn't go in the net so I
think the longest period ever went was
six games I think that's really really
important for a striker you've got to
have a calmness about you as soon as you
get up tight you're going to start
missing stuff and thankfully about that
so is this is about Barcelona Mark
Hughes Terry Venables Terry Venables as
a coach at Boston and Sam who signed
both mark and myself pretty much in the
same day magical time no this just like
the most fun testing Club is it's mad
but it's huge but it is vibrant and it's
just the best pressure boss is intense
but that that's one of the things I I
don't know why but I love pressure and I
joined it I just think it gives you a
chance honey show off what you do and if
you plan for the biggest club and you
know in the biggest games like the
classic and stuff it just kind of
brought out the best in me England again
this time this that is the celebration I
think of the equaliser against Germany
in the semi-final of the World Cup
probably as a one-off the best feeling
ever of my whole career obviously didn't
last much longer because we lost on
penalties that close it's the it's the
one game I think I look back and think
if only the one I remember having a
conversation with Bobby I did Bobby
Robson I did a documentary with him and
he said exactly the same thing that he's
every now and again it almost every day
thinks about that moment it's not every
day me but whenever I see a picture like
that it just reminds me of how close how
close
whereas a team from immortality room it
was tough losing I mean just in the
dressing room after I've gone was just
like just down quiet Bobby was put his
arm around people after a while you get
changed every shower thing we got in the
bus and we had this thing in in Italian
90 where it sounds bizarre but on the
way home after every match after every
training session we used to sing though
female deer and all brand the team don't
ask me why I can't remember why it
started but anyway obviously after the
semi-final loss we're all sitting on the
bus and it's like crying this for the
first time we were given a few beers and
had a couple of beers and eventually the
bus starts to roll and I think it was
always out of the castle Chris Waddle or
probably both they started singing and
then gradually the whole team started
joined in and it was it was kind of a
really odd but very special moment and
very poignant and yeah this is something
I've always remembered well in the FA
Cup whispers I think I think of all the
things I've hand during my career a lot
of them were personal like winning the
Golden Boot and stuff like that which is
I mentioned occasionally but this was
actually most special moment I
desperately wanted to win something
important and the FA Cup was massive in
those days I'm not sure motivations
necessarily change as you get older I
think what happens is your clock starts
ticking towards the end of your career
if things have not worked out here I
mean I think I was runner-up in the
league four times in my career three
times the boss learn room once with once
with Everton and you start to wonder
whether things are going to happen if
you've not won that many that team
prices in you career then the motivation
to win one becomes greater
last picture it smears young boy again
and me with my boys and one lineal Messi
who obviously is my most special boy
it's been an amazing amazing life
can we look back at it mania feel I've
been blessed with some reason which is
works I don't believe in any of you know
that stuff but I just been incredibly
fortunate you know I've got four lads
now they're all in their 20s they're all
growing up we'll have a good time
together I've I've had a remarkable life
really problems been unbelievably good
to me
unbelievably good and I just I just feel
incredibly lucky
I'm Gary Lineker and this is what it
takes
you
[Music]